es la hora de hablar de economía y lo
hacemos de la mano de nuestro periodista
especializado en el tema Jorge Hurtado
Jorge buenas noches bienvenido Buenas
noches María Clara empecemos con los
datos de la economía global porque el
Banco Mundial ya presentó su perspectiva
va a crecer o no va a crecer bueno va a
crecer un dos coma uno por ciento este
año frente al 3,1% que se reportó en
2022 PC al mal dato del último informe
de perspectivas económicas mundiales del
banco supone una leve mejora con
respecto a su anterior previsión de
enero donde previo un crecimiento
mundial de solo el 1,7% para este año
los motivos bueno la subida de los tipos
de interés las repercusiones de la
invasión rusa en Ucrania y los efectos
persistentes de la pandemia Según dice
el organismo para América Latina el
banco mejoró su previsión que pasó del
1,4 al 1,5% de crecimiento para este año
Espera que el pib de Argentina por
ejemplo caiga en menos dos 2% este año
mientras México crecería un 2,5 y Brasil
apenas un
1,2%, estos son los países que lideran
ese ranking de crecimiento según el
Banco Mundial pero en medio de estas
noticias de crecimiento hay indicadores
no tan buenos por ejemplo el Banco
Mundial alerta de crisis financiera en
países emergentes bueno el organismo
hizo un análisis del impacto de la
subida de los tipos de interés que
tendrían en Estados Unidos para los
países en desarrollo según el organismo
la subida de los tipos está
correlacionada con una mayor
probabilidad de crisis financiera en los
países emergentes y en desarrollo
Asimismo la subida del valor del dinero
aumenta la probabilidad de crisis de
deuda soberana de Divisas en regiones
como América Latina que se ven agravadas
con crisis políticas también internas
Pese a que la mayoría de los países
emergentes y en desarrollo Solo han
sufrido algunos daños limitados por
estas recientes tensiones bancarias en
economías avanzadas ahora navegan en
aguas peligrosas cambiamos de tema y
hablemos de las criptomonedas porque ya
lo hablábamos ayer que la comisión de
bolsa y valores de Estados Unidos
demandó a una gran plataforma de
criptomonedas vainas y ahora se suma
coinbase Así es bueno también los acusa
de operar ilegalmente por no haberse
registrado como una bolsa en ese país
ambos casos civiles fueron parte del
mensaje del presidente de la del
regulador que es el carry cransler para
la industria de criptomonedas al que
Durante este día volví a calificar del
salvaje oeste los detalles y los tenemos
a continuación
aumenta la presión contra las
plataformas de criptomonedas justo Un
día después de demandar a binance la
comisión de bolsa y valores de Estados
Unidos tiene en la mira a coinbase la
mayor bolsa de criptomonedas del país
por operar presuntamente como corredor
no registrado coinbase será plenamente
consciente la aplicabilidad de las leyes
federales de valores a sus actividades
comerciales pero deliberadamente se negó
a seguirlas si bien las decisiones
calculadas de coinbase pueden haberle
permitido ganar miles de millones lo ha
hecho expensas de los inversores
privandoles de las protecciones a las
que tienen derecho coinbase contraatacó
culpando al enfoque de los reguladores
la confianza de la sec en un enfoque
basado únicamente en la aplicación de la
ley en ausencia de normas claras para el
sector de los activos digitales está
perjudicando la competitividad económica
de Estados Unidos y a empresas como
coinbase que han demostrado su
compromiso con el cumplimiento Mientras
tanto binance la mayor bolsa de
criptomonedas del mundo y su fundador
fueron acusados el lunes de gestionar
una bolsa ilegal en Estados Unidos y de
engañar a los inversores vainas ha
argumentado durante mucho tiempo que no
está sujeta a las leyes estadounidenses
porque no tiene una sede física en el
país sin embargo Estados Unidos reforzó
su control sobre las plataformas de
criptomonedas especialmente desde la
quiebra de ftx en noviembre del año
pasado la Unión Europea también promulgó
recientemente una ley histórica con
normas para este sector
bueno impresionante esta noticia Jorge
ahora volvamos a hablar de inflación
Porque otro informe que se conoció fue
el de la ocde bueno la inflación en los
países de la ocde se moderó un 0,3
puntos y bajó a 7,4% en abril por debajo
del 7,7% anual reportado en marzo del
2023 de los 38 países de esta
organización 27 registraron una
disminución de los precios otros 10
superó el 10% inflación anual y en
Hungría y Turquía fue mayor al 20% de
inflación anual Reino Unido fue el país
que más desaceleró su inflación anual
pasando del 8,9% anual al 7,8% en abril
Italia registró el mayor aumento de la
inflación general impulsado en gran
medida por el aumento de los precios de
la energía la tasa de inflación
subyacente para esta organización o para
los países que conforman esta
organización que excluye la volatilidad
de alimentos y la energía se sitúa en el
7,1% frente al 7,2 de marzo
Yo apenas un punto y así sigue Incluso
disparada en uno de los incrementos más
grandes de casi los últimos 30 años
ahora sorpréndanos con la cifra del día
13 mil millones de dólares eso generó la
llegada de empresas a México por el New
York según el secretario de Hacienda y
Crédito Público Rogelio Ramírez de la O
este término es la externalización por
la que una empresa transfiere parte de
su producción a terceros que a pesar de
ubicarse en otros países están
localizados en destinos cercanos o con
una zona horaria semejante esta práctica
surge como respuesta a love shoring que
con el objetivo de reducir los costos
Busca proveedores en otros destinos por
lo general en Asia esa tendencia se está
revirtiendo ahora en vez de Buscar Asia
ya están buscando países más cercanos a
Estados Unidos O a grandes economías se
mueve entonces así la economía Jorge
Gracias por todas las noticias y ustedes
sigan con nosotros a continuación
tendremos el debate